ac lui si les habitants peuvent enfin
utiliser leur portable depuis sept mois
une antenne relais à sur le réseau
mobile et la 4g c'est la fin de la zone
blanche et du système d c'est vrai qu
aux alentours sa tournée nickel mais ce
que je dis dans l'huile âge c'était
vraiment limite fallait vraiment trouver
des coins bien et spécifiques pour avoir
accès il fallait que je mette sur la
fenêtre et encore j'avais qu'une barre
alors que 4 12 ans que l'ancien maire
avait lancé les démarches pour qu'une
antenne soit installée à clux si
jusqu'ici là zone n'étaient pas jugés
assez rentable par les différents
opérateurs et à les lourdeurs
administratives allait y avoir pensé
quand on a affaire à des gros
administration is et avait des réponses
la courtoise d'attentes mais après c'est
il faut relancer les toujours il faut
persévérer quoi mais on aboutit en 2018
les tapas un accord avec les quatre
principaux opérateurs mobiles les
fournisseurs ne paye plus la location
des fréquences en échange ils doivent
couvrir les zones dans le besoin ce qui
a pris un petit peu de temps c'est qu'il
a fallu qu'on apprenne à travailler à
quatre opérateurs ce qu'on appelle les
pylônes mutualisé c'est à dire que là
derrière nous il ya un pylône avec les
quatre opérateurs qui reste de la 4g
donc oui ça va plus vite puisque
maintenant on a industrialisé le
processus et les procédures
administratives sont un peu plus allégée
donc ça nous permet de d'installer en
moins de deux ans un pylône appartement
où il est accepté par la population très
spylo de multi opérateurs doivent encore
être installés dans le département
une démarche pas au goût de tous les
habitants en avril dernier trois
antennes ont été dégradées dans les
villes voisines